[Music]
that is not a bachelorette party by the
way no getting wild or letting loose
nikki bella's bachelorette party was
well unconventional mm-hmm thank you
in a sneak-peek clip from Sunday's
episode of total Bellas filmed before
Nikki and John Cena called off their
engagement we see the 34 year old pro
wrestler in Paris enjoying a refined
soiree among a small group of friends
and family determined to spice things up
a bit
Nikki's twin sister brie makes a
suggestion we do like little bears like
and that there is like go show your
boobies like but like you know funny
little things their younger brother JJ
jumped right in with an idea I want you
to get on their table and when one of
the French boys come you have to jump
out scare oh yeah Nikki goes for it but
hilarious it doesn't go as planned Nikki
and John's relationship woes are
currently playing out on this season of
total Bella's I just can't imagine my
life without you John I just can't
imagine not getting married and spending
the rest of our lives to get there et
spoke with John in April shortly after
the couple announced their split now all
your fans want to know how you're doing
how are your feelings since the sad news
about the split what sucks no there's no
other way to say that that's it uh I
love Nicole I'm out and that's a